was machen wir jetzt eine unabhängige
flexible gut aussehende personen frage
ob die bis freitag zeit hat auch die
einfach spontan und uns natürlich auch
vertraut denn wir haben da ein ganz
spezielles projekt du weißt nicht wo du
weißt nicht was in waren hauptsache du
kommst mit uns ja ihr merkt schon ich
habe aber wieder eingepackt wir haben
eine verrückte idee zeit spaß gemacht
letzte mal mit fremden leuten ein
bisschen drauf los zu reisen und
möglicherweise machen heute genau
dasselbe nur noch mal deutlich kassel
also sind wir einfach auf die straße
gegangen und haben noch leute gesucht
die jungs ihr habt ihr bis freitag zeit
gegen das vor über 18
das schlecht
das werde ich bis freitag zeit wenn du
uns contra und würdest
ich hoffe dass sie sehr schlecht aus
niemand alter junge ist ganzen leute
alter oder wir schreiben nun mal spontan
was so ist da die ersten zwei leute die
da sind ja da kommt schnell zum
brüsseler irgendwie sowas habe ich
gesagt merkt schon vielleicht könnte
sich in zukunft lohnen aber nennt bei
inter und youtube zu sein damit ihr
einfach schnell von solchen sachen
bekommt das war definitiv nicht das
letzte mal und wir haben geisteskranke
sagen ja wir sind hier und jetzt heißt
es warten bis die erste person kommt der
zweite kommt ich habe die kommen ja sehr
vor allem checkt man ja mittlerweile da
vermutlich wirklich was meistens
passiert frage hast du zeit bis
freitagabend drauf an
wir können nicht sagen was passiert
das ganze spektakel sind sie auch
also du kannst nicht sage ich komm mit
das weißt du nicht kriegen ja das geht
nicht und aus welchem grund auch immer
waren niemand einfach so dabei niemand
der mir auf der straße gefragt haben und
niemand der direkt dabei gewesen wäre
der über meine in cattolica also kamen
uns die komplette krasseste paroli
bieten und wir haben eine person ein
alter wir haben hier ein neues projekt
am start muss zu arbeiten oder so was
komplett frei bis freitag
es ist nichts schlimmes es ist eine
belohnung für das was du die letzte
woche durchgemacht hast hast du die
letzten wochen durchgemacht hast
natürlich kann man sein bruder ansgar
ich bin der letzte woche über 500
kilometer auf einem fahrrad mit einem
gang mit uns richtung paris gefahren ist
eine menge durchgemacht hat und damit um
17 uhr angerufen um 18 uhr seinen zug
und hatte überhaupt keine ahnung was
jetzt passieren ich glaube ich glaube
der hat noch nichts dabei wir hätten
sagen sollen was hast du mit
hiernach doch klar was passiert wir
müssen vier uhr los natürlich durfte
auch nicht wissen was wir geplant haben
oder was ich nicht ganz verstanden
[Musik]
wie können wir das einfach nicht leben
gekommen waren noch mallorca
habens gas erster flug direkt mit vier
verrückt
doch rausgezogen wegen dem messer im
rucksack ich hab's einfach gemäß seinem
rucksack
mallorca kaputt heute ist am tattag hd
sixx hat ja ja
juli hier
beste colonia studies und weil nicht
jeder von euch einfach so auf der straße
von fremden personen angesprochen werden
kann um in den urlaub zu fliegen und
mainhausen nicht jeder von euch ansgar
sein kann
gibt es eine möglichkeit für 90 prozent
von heute innerhalb von 22 minuten die
urlaubskasse für dieses jahr auch zu
dass dieses video wird unterstützt von
parks liegt eine app die es ermöglicht
durchschnittlich 1000 51 euro steuer
wirkstoff nicht zu bekommen ohne dass
sie irgendwelche vorkenntnissen falls
das vorhin und ich getan hast kannst du
deine letzten vier jahre einreichen und
so bis zu durchschnittlich 4200 euro
über steuerrückerstattung zurück bekommt
das ganze funktionieren superidee app
und über die elster schnittstelle so
dass ihr selber keinen kontakt zum
finanzamt haben müsst ihr könnt quasi
direkt über die app ermitteln die
hochhäuser rückerstattung denn wäre bei
einer rückerstattung über 50 euro kostet
euch das ganze lediglich einen fixbetrag
von 39 eur 99 also ladet euch jetzt die
erste für den ersten link in der video
beschreibung herunter spart 15 prozent
mit dem kot day macht eure
steuererklärung über touch fix und
bessert so die urlaubskasse für dieses
jahr auf oder ist das geld aus für egal
was auch immer wofür ist auch immer
ausgeben muss meiner meinung nach ist
wirklich ein super benutzerfreundliche
app die den einstieg in dieses gesamte
steuer thema wirklich deutlich
vereinfacht ich bedanke mich vielmals
bei touch fix dass sie mich und die
projekte unterstützen das ist möglich
machen dass sich ansgar und meine home
ist herausfliegen eine gute zeit haben
und dieses video hier drehen können tost
antragstext jetzt geht es weiter mit dem
video natürlich ging es auch milch kam
bestens gespeist aber ich hatte mir dann
noch so ein paar sachen für den tag
überleben
die jungs waren wir eigentlich schon
jetski fahren
ja ich habe bei uns war 3 jetskis geholt
[Musik]
was ist auch der rückfahrt ins netz gibt
es erst für die ganze welt hat er sich
das erstmal schlafen und dann hat der
checker ist ja alles auf der kamera
drauf und dann wollte halt die kamera im
diese runterreißen
[Musik]
so heimlich kamera wieder drauf gesteck
tanz kabarett
erst mal außerhalb von deutschland
direkt komplett voll war das erzählt
dass du kennst fühlen wir dich heute war
ein bisschen ans glücken springen heran
mein lieber bist du schon mal klippen
kannst du schwimmt sie an die mutter von
ansgar wir passen auf ihren sohn auf
also keine sorge
jetzt also das was von magdeburg stage
auf die malediven
alter
[Musik]
keine kopie gewartet alter
krank
10 von 10
das ist die belohnung für in paris trage
das war's mit dem video wir haben auch
unfassbar keine zeit gehabt haben danach
noch einen tag komplett auf kamera
urlaub gemacht mit ansgar bewahren
unterwegs hat eine menge spaß vielen
dank an touch fix dass sie dieses video
möglich gemacht haben ich hoffe ich ja
das video gefallen ein jahr das man
gerne leica vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren wir sehen uns nächste woche
macht's gut